the countdown to 11 and the gang's big
showdown with wekner and the mind flayer
has begun and it looks like the upside
downs villains could well win the next
battle it is over 11. you have freed me
you can't stop this now with elle's
failure to beat the big bad foreshadowed
when dustin rolled on 11 and failed to
beat vachna in his dnd game at the start
of season four
yippee kai movie lovers i'm jan and in
this video i'm explaining all the clues
to why eleven and co may need to use
time travel to eventually defeat the
show's villains spoilers and speculation
ahead so take care the idea of time
travel and stranger things was heavily
hinted at towards the end of season
three when dustin erica steve and robin
stumbled into a screening of back to the
future einstein has just become the
world's first time traveler and right
off the bat in season four in eleven's
opening scene she says this today is day
185 feels more like 10 years joyce says
time is funny like that emotions can
make it speed up or slow down we are all
time travelers if you think about it the
idea that happy or sad feelings can
affect the way we perceive time is
analogous to how eleven draws on joyful
memories like her mother's love to take
down one in their first confrontation
versus how vechna exploits his victims
feelings of guilt and sorrow to trap
them then kill them and there are clues
right from the pilot episode through
seasons two and three then four that
time in its representation through clock
motifs will be crucial to understanding
and defeating the villains of the upside
down for starters we know that one hated
the way humans use time to impose their
own sense of order on the world
something we see during his villain's
monologue while a young henry creel
stares at the creel house grandfather
clock seconds minutes hours days weeks
months years decades each life a faded
lesser copy of the one before the way he
reverses the hands on the grandfather
clock not only points to his disdain for
the norms of how time usually works but
it's also a little clue to time reversal
and travel in the show and given the
alice in wonderland reference via his
sister's name it looks like a fairy tale
when the young henry kills a rabbit it's
not surprising as it's like he's killing
the character who was obsessed with time
in the lewis carol's story it's also
curious how all the way back in the
first season when eleven makes her first
contact with the demogorgon the event
that rips open a gate to the upside down
in hawkins there's the sound of a clock
ticking while she's in the void hinting
at wechner's presence in the background
[Music]
there's also a chiming sound effect in
season one's first episode after will
sees the demogorgon and falls off his
bike
then at the very end of season 2 episode
4 after hopper goes into the
mineflayer's tunnels you can hear the
sound of a clock ringing
and in the third season just after the
mind flayer possesses billy and he gets
pulled into the upside down there's the
sound of clocks chiming in the
background
and after billy comes out of that vision
you can also hear a gong as he staggers
around suffering from being in the heat
and the sun
[Music]
the hawkins clock tower also appears in
the first shot of the horror in the
heartland news report in season 3 which
is also another back to the future
easter egg given the importance of the
clock tower to time travel in that movie
and thanks to two of our amazing movie
lovers rebecca strain and ariana for
noticing that max's counselor ms kelly
wears a clock necklace which i think
also looks rather like a key a possible
hint that time will be the answer to how
the gang eventually defeat wekner
another possibility for this detail is
that it's a hint that ms kelly is being
used in some way by vechna or the mind
flayer similar to how will and billy
were spies for the villain after all max
discovered the therapist had been
helping chrissy and fred both of whom
end up as vacna's victims fred was seen
miss kelly too another clock related
detail that another of our awesome movie
lovers chris valner pointed out is how
black widow spiders often have hourglass
markings on their abdomen something you
can see when a young henry creel is
drawing one a lethal clue also to how
once feckner ensnares you the countdown
begins to your death
there's also a deep cut time related
connection between one and watchmen as
the same musical theme plays when one
reveals his origin story as also plays
during the birth of dr manhattan like
stranger things watchmen heavily
features clock motifs and dr manhattan
also has the ability to experience time
in a non-linear way both the awakening
of henry creel's powers and dr
manhattan's birth take place in 1959
and on top of that the main events of
season four take place in 1986. the same
year that the watchmen comics were first
published and the way eleven evaporates
one into dust sending him into the
upside down where he becomes wekner has
parallels with the way john ostermann is
evaporated by accident during a
radioactive particle test and disappears
before becoming dr manhattan
now a character a lot of you have been
asking about is eight aka carly eleven's
lost sister who she met back in season
two she's mentioned in season four by
one when he's talking to eleven do you
remember the day a strange woman came to
see you this would have been when eight
was still here it seems pretty clear
then the eight used her powers to cast
illusions to escape the lab before one
went on his rampage and killed the other
test subjects and i think she'll be back
before everything is over to help eleven
take down wekner and the mine player or
given her hatred of brenner and the
hawkins lab it's possible she could ally
with one instead in fact there was some
foreshadowing of her return in the
crossword that brenna completes in the
opening scene one of the clues is for
the wife of shiva the answer to which is
kali in the hindu tradition kali is a
goddess of time change and death and
perhaps together with eleven they will
find a way to reverse an event in time
also next to the crossword in that
newspaper is another clock related
easter egg with an ad for a jewelers and
watchmakers who offer watch repairing
services now if any of these clues seem
too coincidental it's worth remembering
that the duffer brothers have said that
right from the very beginning of the
series they wrote a 25-page document
which outlined all the mythology for the
show and the upside down and how it
worked plus the show's set decorator has
said that every item every tiny piece of
set dressing is intentional so dustin
sherlock holmes quote the world is full
of obvious things which nobody by any
chance ever observes is basically
telling us that the clues and answers to
the mysteries behind stranger things are
all laid out in the little details in
the show on top of that before it was
renamed stranger things the original
title for the show was montauk montauk
is the name of a real-life place on long
island which has inspired numerous
conspiracy theories about experiments
carried out at the military base there
according to wikipedia a book called the
montauk project experiments in time
claims experiments at the government
facility opened a porthole in time that
allowed travel to anywhere in time or
space via a time tunnel the book also
describes the time an alien monster
travelled through the tunnel causing
damage and killing numerous people
before it was killed a lot of evidence
then points to time travel playing some
crucial part in stranger things before
the final season is over and the duffer
brothers have said that this part of
season four is the beginning of the end
so to quote the time manipulating wizard
doctor strange we're in the end game now
i think it's possible that season four
will end on a cliffhanger perhaps a
tragedy affecting one of the main
characters that will need some kind of
time travel to fix this could be similar
to avengers infinity war where the
heroes lose and many of them seemingly
die only to eventually return an end
game when the avengers use time travel
to fix things the most extreme outcome
could be that all the show's events are
undone so that 11 is never taken from
her mother and lives a normal happy life
i don't think that wiping out the entire
story would be especially popular with
audiences though so let's hope
whatever's planned is something more
interesting than that funnily enough
there was a rick and morty easter egg in
season 4 via the name rick sanchez which
appears on the list of ricks that the
gang searches for at the video store
interestingly rick and morty a show
which features multiple alternate
universes initially had a no time travel
rule until it introduced a whole episode
to show why time travel was such a bad
idea of course stranger things is always
loaded with incredible details such as
the hidden sound effect that reveals how
as a child henry creel might have gotten
his powers from the upside down which i
explained in my season 4 easter eggs
video tap here to watch that or follow
the link in the video description so
movie lovers how do you think time
travel will end up being used in
stranger things or do you think there's
another way to defeat bechner and the
mind player let me know in the comments
below next tap here for my full
breakdown of the ending of volume 1 and
what else to expect in the big part 2
finale and if you liked this video do
leave a thumbs up i really appreciate it
thanks for enjoying stranger things with
me and hope you have a marvellous movie
loving week yippee kai movie lovers